here's your breath
that's it you can use your hands
you can use these uh
in the face
the chin
you can strike the chin
okay change
here with you next
okay that's done
[Applause]
that's it
[Music]
not too fast
go to them
good
who'd you go to them
go to them don't stand there
go to them weave your way in and out
them
that's better that's better see if you
can get them all down before they get
out
good okay okay
you're nearly made it so that that's
Coke and egg you can't just stand out or
attack me please I want to throw you
about you've got a weave
okay second breath third breath whatever
you need
okay here
we don't go to them
go to them
good this is
that's it go to them
not too far
not too quick
okay Scrappy now
a good way it's Scrappy but that was
very good example
who's next
trying to breather
I really like a breather tough you can't
have it go
you're going for senior day and grades
after just find it
grab them go to go to them
that's it so you're trying dead right
now so use your breath
not strength but breath
turn go to them turn
time
okay no good whatsoever a worn out old
I won't say because the sun might
um
Jim is that just leave Jim
good
that's it nice and busy and controlled
good down
foreign
gems was nice
Eileen are you trying to use a bit too
much strength so you can only use what
you got they're attacking you so you
just turn quick